♪ (country) ♪
- Nancy Cerroni passe des heures
chaque semaine à la rencontre
des chevaux sauvages, les fameux
mustangs de l'Ouest américain.
Cela fait 17 ans qu'elle les
observe dans les montagnes
Prior, au Wyoming, tout près
de la frontière avec le Montana.
Elle en a recensé elle-même
185 dans ce parc naturel
et elle les connaît tous
par leur nom.
Ce matin, ils sont quelques-uns
à se nourrir de sauge
sur le bord de la route.
Ils nous ignorent presque
en traversant pour aller
boire l'eau du lac.
Ce spectacle si apaisant
et si magique ferait presque
oublier que ces chevaux sont
trop nombreux dans 10 tstststs
de l'Ouest : plus de 90 000.
Ce qui cause des problèmes
pour la faune et la flore
environnantes.
Alors, périodiquement,
les autorités fédérale en
captur m m m m mettre moins
de pression sur les écosystèmes
et en prennent soin.
Mais il y en a beaucoup.
La solution :
les offrir en adoption.
Adopter un mustang, c'est
ce qu'a fait Amy, au Montana.
Passionnée de chevaux,
elle a accueilli Harper.
Adopter Harper ne lui a pas
coûtéchchchchchcher.
25 $ pour ce mustang,
mais elle a dû prévoir
quelques milliers de dollars
pour l'entraîne s s s s s sûr,
l'enclos nécessaire. Et il y a
une autre chose à considérer.
Depuis 50 ans,
plus de 240 000 chevaux
sauvages ont été adoptés
ou vendus à des éleveurs.
Mais la demande est bien
plus faible que l'offre,
et la sécheresse, qui cause
la famine, n'arrange rien.
7000 autres bêtes qui vont
grossir davantage les rangs
du cheptel à adopter.
Pour Nancy Cerroni, le contrôle
de cette surpopulation de
façon humaine est essentiel.
♪ ♪ ♪
L'adoption reste donc
la priorité pour les autorités
fédérales, afin que ce symbole
de l'Ouest américain continue
d'évoluer dans ces plaines
et ces montagnes.
Des chevaux si adorés
par Nancy, qui continue,
en attendant, de les aimer
tous autant qu'ils sont.